the film that predicted the technology
of the future we're talking about
Disney's first science fiction flick
Tron which was directed by Stephen
lisberger it tells the story of a hacker
in virtual reality back in 1982 very few
people had computers yet Stephen
lisberger managed to show the world
about digital identity artificial
intelligence personal data and
confidentiality long before windows or
even flash droids this movie had touch
screens online avatars and even the
metaverse indeed Tron was ahead of its
time two ahead of its time and this
meant that many people ended up
dismissing the movie in fact the arcade
game based on Tron was more popular than
the film itself Tron was disqualified at
the Oscars where it was nominated for
best visual effects because its use of
CGI was considered to be a scam a full
15 minutes of the film consisted of 100
computer Graphics this
very sad only like this video if you
want to hear more about movies that
predicted the future